Jennifer Lawrence looking chic at Paris
Fashion Week making her first public
appearance since cook Maroney popped the
question so all eyes on that bling the
diamond ring is estimated at five carats
the total cost of the ring between 150
and 250 thousand dollars alright
meanwhile everybody in the free world
still waiting for Jennifer Lopez's man
to pop the question a rod what's up but
you know what she has been rockin bling
from head to toe yeah JLo is having a
moment and the queen of the Oscars
carpet was clearly feeling herself after
trading in the mirrored Tom Ford
masterpiece for this futuristic
afterparty look J Lo's got more than a
few reasons to dance it out she slayed
the fashion game this awards season her
twins Max and Emmy just turned 11 can
you believe she had a rod already
celebrated two years it feels like we're
starting life all over again
and tonight the 49 year old boss lady
rocking some impeccable style is back on
your TV for season three of world of
dance this season the competition for a
million bucks is next level we're just
like what did we just see what just
happened and we love how J Lo's
inspiring the contestants you show us
that we could do anything that we want
thank you and her fellow judges I find
myself having to having to match her
energy but what makes this mama really
proud it's a family show there's not a
lot of shows like I know when I'm at
home watching shows and stuff you know
my kids walk in there go are you
watching Game of Thrones we can't watch
this right yeah it's like no you can't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]